foreign
this article some people have been
sending it to me it's been making waves
and it's just it's borderline hilarious
but here's the headline from
nottheby.com the average American needs
to earn how much to feel financially
secure
and it goes on to say Americans feel
they would need to earn approximately
233 thousand dollars a year on average
to be secure or comfortable with their
finances from a new survey that's around
19 a month per person
I don't know if it's household it
doesn't really say but if single people
took the survey too so you know I
imagine that's in there here's the
crazier part to consider themselves rich
or possessing Financial Freedom the
average American would need to pull 483
thousand dollars according to the survey
they said that's how much I would need
I'm confused I'm shook really that is
wild considering uh the average earnings
full-time year-round workers in 2021 was
75 grand according to the Census Bureau
so they need uh triple that well I'm
just thinking like stat wise like the
percentage of people who earn
250 plus a year
well I think when you're it's not
financially insecure you over index on
how much I need to feel very secure yeah
you know when you're frightened out of
your mind like I need a million dollars
to feel like I'm safe and that's what
this goes on to talk about it says
Americans are more than two times more
likely to feel financially insecure than
secure only one in four said they're
completely financially secure it's
probably the folks that follow the
Ramsey babies I was going to say it's
the people who have good financial
habits that's right and the rest said
uh-uh not me and a lot of people say
it's economic factors that are keeping
them from feeling financially secure of
course they're blaming the rising
interest rates and inflation and the
cost of living and the housing market
and lifestyle and it's just it never
ends but I some people were honest Jade
some said one in four blamed high or
evolving debt as the problem which at
least they're self-aware to go debt is
my problem because I think truthfully
for most people it's debt and it's
lifestyle that's right yeah yeah yes
inflation yes groceries but this idea
that the the cause everyone's shaking
their fists at the cost of eggs yeah yes
that's not the solution to your problems
is eggs being three dollars more than
they were yeah no if if it's your 700
car payment yeah if egg prices going up
is ruining your world you've got bigger
issues going on exactly facts so this
says highlighting wealth gaps and
varying costs of living many Americans
feel they need even more to pay more pay
than the national average and here's it
what's interesting women on average say
they need to earn roughly 237 K annually
or about 500 000 a year to feel rich so
more than men I wonder if that's because
women have the security gland is
stronger where they they want that
Security even more I have so many
questions yeah George this is evoking
many questions within me I don't have
the answers I'm simply a message Bearer
well I'm thinking well here's what I'm
thinking I'm going okay the more money
you have
the more margin that you should have if
you're handling it correctly and a lot
of folks that I know that have high
incomes like this they're not spending
all of the money like it's not part of
their
they have a lot of extra that they're
like okay I can give this and I can
invest this and but it's not like oh
great now I can go see more movies and
now I can buy more steaks and now I can
does that make sense like at the end of
the day you're gonna come to a point
where it's like this is my lifestyle and
I've just got to be able to manage my my
lifestyle anything on top of that is
gravy and it's cool but it sounds like
these people just want if if you can
just learn to manage your lifestyle
without a bunch of creep without a bunch
of inflated habits you would be happy
probably with the 75 000 oh which is the
average we've seen the stats of hey
people who make six figures they're
living a paycheck to paycheck too and
you go I wish I made that kind of money
I wouldn't be like that you don't know
yeah yeah a third of people making 250
000 a year or living paycheck to
paycheck that's right and so if you
think that income is gonna just solve
all of your problems it's only part of
the equation and truthfully the more you
make the more you're gonna spend unless
you're on a proven plan where you're
living on less than you make and you're
you're investing for the future and
you're staying out of debt so I want to
encourage you guys that you don't need
to make 233 thousand dollars to be
financially secure because I meet people
that visit us that do their debt free
scream and their teachers and their
engineers and they're making 40 60 70 80
000 and their life is great oh yeah and
they can pay off their homes they can
invest for the future and the big factor
that allows them to do that is not their
income that's right it's their ability
to manage money instead of manage debt
and too many of you all are in the debt
management game instead of the money
management game and you think you're
crushing it because you're paying off
your card every month but you don't feel
like you're making track yeah you're not
making traction because you're playing
the credit card companies game that's
right you're not building your net worth
you're just helping a credit card
company sponsor their next stadium
so start playing your own game start
running your own race get out of debt
regardless of your income yes get your
income up and some people are trapped
because they're making 30 grand a year
and they need to go make more money and
get some education and step into a
different career but that's not the
solution to your problems yeah
absolutely I know plenty of people who
make the like mid-range six figures and
it ain't all it's cracked up to be for
them because they have not learned the
principles that we teach on the show
every day and so you know unfortunately
the more your lifestyle goes up a lot of
people it that lifestyle creep is so
real we need to do a segment on how to
know when to you know when there's a
tease yeah how can you know when to
Lifestyle like upgrade your lifestyle
increase your lifestyle without it being
the negative lifestyle creep that keeps
people from I guess because we get a bad
rap for me like they don't want us to
spend money no we want you to spend
money yeah that you haven't budgeted for
without sacrificing your future that's
it well there's the segment right there
George you just explained it